how can her consent be solicited you
know how can you get the consent of the
Virgin watch what Muhammad says he said
they that she keeps silence so her
silence is her consent the little virgin
if she's quiet that's that's a that's a
yep you got you got the green light bro
I don't know what to tell you because
you don't think that's crazy listen what
the hell like bro listen I'm telling you
straight up like that's not the Islam I
follow I don't know what your put
I have not enough knowledge to debate
you on this I'm just going to be
straight up I don't have I'm not a
scholar Z hi hello hello hi did you have
a question or
comment so as a muslam I feel like it's
important to come with to come with a
respect and and PE and that's how we
like you know treat everybody but my
question is you know how you say Islam
is false changed my mind yeah like what
is it that you don't like is there
questions that you have like what is it
that you don't understand about say
because I feel like go ahead yeah at
this point of my life it's not things
that I don't understand it's the things
that I do understand that causes me to
conclude that Islam is false it's not
from a place of ignorance I looked into
some these issues and I see that these
things are incorrect not not coh just
because like growing up in the west I
know that after 91 there has been like
you know the
stereotypical ostracization and villain
villainization of Muslims in general
like you know if you see a a Muslim man
with a beard you would automatically
assume he's a te if you saw a practicing
Muslim you would automatically think
she's you know conservative she's
oppressed and all of these things so my
like on it is like a lot of those kinds
of convers ations that people are like
change my mind which you obviously
probably aren't having these types of
conversations like that but there are so
many people who are just really really
ignorant to the faith and so my my
advice would be to anybody on here is
just to to really like explore the faith
but read the Quran with an open mind
because I think if if there's a religion
from my experience that teaches
discipline and that teaches motivation
and that really adheres to the
principles of the faith that's Islam
that's only
because I just feel like that's my
problem go ahead that's my problem the
Quran teaches you to do a lot of really
wrong things that are not godly and that
are not in line with the true God that's
my that's my problem there's a lot of
things yeah well like can you give me an
example that you that where you think
they're that they aren't Godly or like
what do you mean sure so a huge issue
from for me is the issue where it
permits relations with girls who have
not hit puberty yet that's a huge now
I'm not talking about oh if that's okay
in time no no there's never a time where
it's okay for a grown man to have
relations with a with a girl with a
minor girl who has no it's never okay no
I completely agree with I I I actually
completely agree with you I think there
is no time for that that and that
obviously an awful and horrifying thing
and and I think what you're referring to
is Muhammad s alhi wasallam and you know
AA basically you're referring to the
time where a lot of people come up with
this because you know they say that you
know a 9-year-old s go ahead sorry sorry
okay go ahead so although the Muslim
sist do point to that as a reference
that's not what I'm actually talking
about what the Quran itself
says gives an allow
a per a permission for young girls to be
married off divorced you know had
relations with when it comes to adult
men and stuff it allows that so that's
in that's in the Quran that's what I'm
talking about I mean I'm so sorry I was
coughing so I like I didn't hear the
middle part that you
said yeah yeah I was just coughing and I
was like I had to mute myself but just
can you just repeat the middle part so
that I could actually get get what you
said yes I was just saying that it's
it's the Quran itself that allows for
relations with girls who haven't hit
puberty yet it's the Quran that does
that so yes there's stuff like that in
Muhammad Anda but that's for me that's
secondary issue the Quran is primary
because that's supposed to be the word
of Allah itself
so so essentially you're saying that
Islam promotes
pilia yes yes wow that is a statement
and a half it's a very yeah no no no I
mean that is an assumption that is a
statement that That's Heavy I agree but
I think to say that the whole book
promotes pure is is is crazy I mean I
can show
you I wouldn't say the whole book I
would just say that there's a place in
the book that allows for for that I can
I can show you if you would like so it's
in chapter 16 5 verse 4 oh you have it
nice who me off the big screen yeah we
we'll we we'll read it out as for your
women past the age of ministration in
case you do not know their waiting
period their Ida is three months and
those who have not ministr as well Lam
yna as for those who are pregnant their
waiting period ends with delivery and
whoever is mindful of a
he will make their matters easy for them
all right so just to be specific let's
break this down slowly so this ver is
talking about divorce like that's
literally what the chapter name is it's
t means divorce right now it gives you
three categories of females it gives you
the first category are the ones who are
too old to menr read that part one more
time the beginning yeah and as for your
women past the age of ministration I
pause there so so they're divorcing
women who are past the age
Administration right and so now they
have these women they have what is
called an ID which is the waiting period
before she can move on to another man
and the waiting is to make sure that
she's not pregnant so it's it's three
months to make sure she's not pregnant
so there's no confusion who the baby
father is and daugh soth right so older
women when you divorce them their
waiting period is three
months and it also says the same for
those who have not ministr as well so
now so girls who have not even ministr
are also being divorced and their
waiting period is also 3 months and then
for the pregnant woman when she's
getting divorced her waiting period is
until she delivers the baby so our
contention is with the second category
the second group which are the ones who
have not ministr yet so they're divorce
they're divorcing girls what um sorry i'
I've got a sore throat so I'm not trying
to okay no no I'm not trying to breathe
into your mic like that but no I'm
really conscious of the fact that
there's like 650 people on here but I'm
like I've got a real cold but anyway
this is a chill crowd I proba we're
chill here we we chill we're we're
lighthearted okay it's all right okay so
from the verse that you read right I've
actually pulled it up CU I read that
before and basically in my understanding
to it we're talking about obviously
when're talking about those who have not
menstruated it's in reference to those
who are above puberty but who haven't
mated to haven't had their monthly P
monthly cycle yet it doesn't refer to
children because obviously talking about
the L which is divorce but that's it's
talking about those who are with child
who are who are you know having their
monthly cycle those who could
potentially be pregnant obviously to
avoid confusion with baby father and
obviously in Islam we really do like
value women so much so that you know you
can't just divorce a pregnant woman
while she's about to give birth to your
child so that's actually a sin to do
that and Men Can't divorce pregnant
women if they're expecting their baby
they got to they've got to wait till she
delivers so that it's not a stressful
pregnancy and from my understanding it
talks about the fact that if she hasn't
had her monthly cycle you just have to
wait that she's not pregnant do you see
why we but of course so so this is why
this is why you know I mean because the
verse says that they haven't minated at
all the the word in Arabic is
ledna ledna meaning they have not
minated in the past it's never happened
ledna so they've never ministr right and
so just just to let you know that this
isn't just like my interpretation or you
know just me misinterpreting the verse
if we go to the scholars I want to show
you what the scholars said this is iban
cir IB cath breaks this down
and tells us what it's talking about
exactly go ahead black doctor so just
look I the Islamic scholar really held
high when it comes to a chanic
interpretation and history and stuff so
and we'll show you more it's not just
him we'll show you what they all say
they all are have a consensus on this
all the Islamic scholars go ahead and
read that up you do the ID of those in
menopause and those who do not have men
Allah the exalted clarifies the waiting
period
of the woman in menopause and that is
the one whose menstration has stopped
due to her older age her ID is three
months instead of the three monthly
cycles for those who menstrate which is
based upon the Ayah andah Al Bak the
same for the young who have not reached
the years of
ministration their Ida is three months
like those in menopause this is the
meaning of his saying and for those who
have no courses so that's that's iath
very authoritative and he makes it clear
that the understanding of this verse is
that it's talking about women in
menopause right those are too old to
have their ministration and then also
it's talking about young girls who are
too young to have ministrate they
haven't reach the age where they can
ministrate yet so even he is saying yeah
the Quran is pretty clear on this the
these are the ones that are being
divorced now if you don't mind I'll show
you a couple more I'm going to get the
big screen now just to show you like
it's not we're not just picking and
choosing you know it's not us making
stuff up we're not picking choosing I
can show you we'll show you just a few
all of them all of them say the same
thing there's not one that's different
so this is jalalain these are two
Scholars together the two jalals they
call them right so he's you know
breaking down the verse and as for those
of your women who no longer expect me to
minate if you have any doubts about
their waiting period they're prescribed
waiting period shall be 3 months and
also for those who have not yet
ministrate because of their young age
their period shall be three months both
cases apply to other than those whose
spouses have died so they you know go on
talking about the pregnant women and y y
y so that's that right so even Jalan
gives it about young girls who have not
administrated yet um we already read
iate the let's read let's go down here
to Mali maludy so here it says now they
may not have menr as yet either because
of young age or delayed minstral
discharge as it happens in the case of
some women or because of no discharge at
all throughout life which
though rare may also be the case in any
case the waiting period of such a woman
is the same as of the woman who has
stopped Administration that is 3 months
from the time divorced was pronounced so
even Mal Duty includes young girls as
being part of this category of ones who
have not yet ministr right so he he
talks about it's they're young or they
are you know they have a little issue
you know delayed
discharge right a medical issue which is
rare but can be a case as well so he
includes both that's talking about girls
who haven't administrated yet and also
ones who maybe have a physical
disability all right so um here it is
therefore making mention of the waiting
period of the girls who have notrated
this is important therefore making
mention of the waiting period of the
girls who have not yet menr clearly
proves that it is not only permissible
to give away the girl in marriage at
this age but it is also permissible for
the husband to consummate marriage with
her so these are the what all the
scholars are saying if you want to a
comment you can yeah I'm literally just
listening to you no I mean so Islam
basically long story short like I don't
want to monologue or anything but Islam
came to cover all rare cases all kind of
cases scen like any scenario possible it
tries to allude to any random weird
scenario as possible because it is the
book like we consider Islam and the
Quran to be the last Revelation so for
basically for mankind there's not going
to be another revelation after the Quran
that's what Muslims believe right so
even in situations where you're
referring to what you would consider
Like Girls before their period and stuff
personally I'm I didn't see any
reference to child or children and also
when looking at you know the idea of
periods in Islam and like cleanliness is
a part of our Dean so it's a part of our
religion right there is a big importance
that's why Muslims are generally very
very very hygienic people we wash down
there five times a day we do all the W
which involves washing like you'll never
find a stinky Muslim like if they on
Dean they are not smelly because we are
we are told to purify ourselves as much
as possible and we are rewarded for that
right so in reference to periods when
you're talking about the menstruation
cycle it's really important to
recognize that Islam forbids a man to to
divorce his wife while she's on her
period there is nothing wrong with him
marrying her during that time but he
cannot consummate so he cannot have sex
with her while she's on her period
that that talks that talks about you
know it could you know damage her insid
you're not supposed to generally like no
no I get what you're saying I'm coming
back I know I promise you I'm coming
back to the part where where you're
talking about where you're talking about
menstruation but just essentially like
you cannot cons in Islam you cannot
consumate a marriage um if she's on her
period she has to be clean like that is
a big thing in reference to you talking
about periods and in there
three month period sorry I'm not talking
about just simply
periods I'm talking about girls you
haven't reached that period yes yes the
reason why is because they're too young
look you see like I I we showed you this
and all of them said this the same for
the young who have not reached the years
of ministration what does that mean for
young girls who haven't the years where
they're able to what does that well I
mean realistically Islam came over 1400
years ago at a time where child marriage
even in the west you know child marriage
incest all of that was very very very
normal that doesn't mean it is something
that we promote or we tell children to
do because if that was the case I would
have been married at nine only back down
logic that's what she trying to say
sorry sorry the words of Allah could
only apply back down right is that what
you're saying it cannot apply no no I'm
not saying that respect like I please
don't put words in my mouth because I I
didn't finish you just interrupted me
that was not what I was saying okay yeah
I mean I'm not alluding I I really
wasn't trying to yeah yeah it's okay
okay so basically that was the time
where it was a big thing right so it's
important to recognize that
children as young as nine even younger
than nine were being married off sorry
yeah speaking about what other nations
do is not relevant to what the Quran is
teaching if the Quran itself is
permitting this then it's permitting
something that is wrong no matter
whether it was something normal people
were doing or not which is not true but
just granting it even if it was normal
for people to be doing this sick act
it's still sick it's still wrong okay so
I need you to focus on this that the
Quran look the same for the young young
who have not reached the years of
Administration they're the ones who are
being divorced married and slept with
you see what I'm saying I understand
your logic entirely and I'm not trying
to be rude when I ask you this question
but you know how there's like the Old
Testament and the New Testament and
there are some violent verses in
different scriptures right how do people
consider and take that into
consideration when they you know promote
peace when some Biblical scriptures and
some talmudic scriptures are incredibly
violent and also promote the unive UN
alement of innocent people yet people
completely IGN that because they say
that let me you I'll answer you real
quick and bring you back the difference
the difference is is that number those
people are innocent these are entire
nations that have rebelled against God
sacrificed their children have origies
rebel against God they continuously sin
and in fact before God sent Israel into
battle against these nations to take
their land as his judgment against them
for sin he gave them 400 years he gave
them 400 years to turn to God to repent
of their sin and their idolatry before
God cast his judgment on them to wipe
them out or to take their land and give
it to Israel so he gave them time and he
put up with their sin for a very long
time before he finally cast his judgment
on those Nations so we have we have
instances where God gives his wrath on a
nation because of their sin this is not
that this is talk this is a
permissibility for men to marry sleep
with and divorce divorce like you know
immature girls um okay with your logic
how many 9-year-old Muslim girls do you
know that are married to 65 year old men
if we pull up online we we have a few
matter of fact there was recently I
don't know if it's about a year ago now
where a young girl I believe she was I
believe she was either seven or or 10
where she got she got married to a man
he consumated the marriage with her and
she died that night okay well with Islam
right we have um categories and we have
what's it called like you need to
fulfill these categories in order to get
married so I can pull that out for you
to show you but a lot of Islam is
literally common sense and it it tells
us to it invokes us to to use our
intellect it's not it's not a religion
for dumb people like you're not supposed
to blindly follow Islam Islam is backed
by science and everything like that but
I'm not going to start on a monologue
there is literally like a Cate there are
four I think more than four but there
are categories that you must fulfill as
Muslims to be able to get married if you
don't fill those then you cannot get
married I have the one of those one of
those conditions is that you need to be
able to like take up a responsibility
like you are supposed to you know be
able to basically be able to be a wife
or be able to be a husband I personally
do no it's true because a nine-year-old
cannot take on household I have I have
according to to your Islamic scholar
your Juris Prudence I have the ruling of
marriage and what makes them qualified I
have it right here I have you read it to
me so I can go ahead so look so this is
the Encyclopedia of jurist prudence
right so the the ruling now here's the
issue that's being brought up here
second section the ruling on marrying a
young girl so what what's the what's the
ruling on that the first issue the
father's marriage to a young virgin
daughter it is permissible for the
father to marry his young virgin
daughter now just to be clear guys it's
not saying that a father can marry his
own daughter it's saying that a father
can give his virgin daughter in marriage
okay so let's just be clear I don't want
you guys going around saying oh look
it's it no let's be clear let's be fair
and let's read with understanding it's
not saying that a father can marry his
own daughter it's saying that a father
can marry off his young daughter all
right so let's just make clear all right
so we got that understood so it is
permissible for the father to marry his
young virgin daughter off basically
without her permission this is agreed
upon by the four schools of jurist
prudence hanafi why does it say un
ownership hanafi uh I think uh Shafi hes
what is this malakes I don't know why I
mistranslated that right there and it
was reported that there was consensus on
this so they all agreed that a father is
per is permissible for a father to marry
off his young his his little girl
without her permission now what's the
evidence they give they give reasoning
here's the evidence first from the book
itself from the Quran what verse do they
quote to back up the evidence that a
father is is is permitted to give his
little girl in marriage here it is God
Almighty said and for those of your
women who have despaired of ministration
if you are in doubt their waiting period
is 3 months and those who have not
ministrate so it's the same it's alock
verse four exactly what we just read
earlier 654 so that's what they use now
what is the meaning right so here's the
Here's the final part I able to can I
just am I able to interject or are you
gonna finish your point uh let let me
just read Because this is important
that's fine go ahead so so they quote
the Quran verse and then they say the
meaning behind the evidence that they're
using so it says God almighty ruled that
the divorce of a young girl who has not
minated is valid and divorce does not
occur except in a valid marriage so the
verse includes the
permissibility of marrying a young girl
there is no party with whom her marriage
is valid unless her father marries her
so the condition is that her father
gives her a marriage and actually this
is a mistranslation not young girl it's
a minor girl a little girl right s yeah
exactly brother yeah and and and then uh
logic just to finish it would you be
able to read the third matter as well
since you already had it on third matter
if you scroll down I I wanted to touch
on this first she wanted okay I got you
I got you I got you
something again Zena this is the this is
the consensus the ruling the official
ruling of you know of what of the law on
marrying young girls no I completely and
okay I'm not going to say completely CU
I don't because I don't understand how
we're referring to a Sur that's on which
is divorce to talk about marriage but
I'm just going to say this is what I've
this is the I I'll pull up a I'll read
this okay it says it is Haram for the
guardian to the Wally of the woman to
force her to marry someone she does not
want or does not like the prophet bless
it the prophet muhamad s wasam peace and
blessings upon him said the Virgin
should not be given in marriage until
her per has been sought this is narrated
by alari Muslim and this basically says
that you cannot marry off your daughter
so I couldn't even be married off
without my father coming to me and
asking me if it's okay or then my nikah
so that's Islamic marriage would not be
valid in that case that's why every
single Force marriage in Islam is not
considered a valid nah so it's basically
it's it's n and void it doesn't exist so
she could go Mar next man that's logic
um also if you talk can you give us that
Hadi please I just I just read just just
give us the Hadith please it says it is
Haram for the guardian give us the sorry
it was narrated by alkari in sah Muslim
1419 goari 1419 this is the
sorry want open my I show you my C do
you want me to like show you it okay you
could just give us the Hadith number not
a problem if it's from alari not only
that but if we're going with the
virgin's consent we got to see what what
her consent is sister if you're uh if
you're there you probably concentrating
on something here I'm here sorry no I'm
listening but he just wants me because
he thinks I'm not making St like I don't
have
time um and then I'm talking about cuz I
literally it says it here do you see and
then it's also talking about whe because
I'm curious to learn about my religion
as well like I'm not a scholar like that
so when you say things I want to check
them as well so then it talks about and
then it talks about marriage and like
why a falce marriage is it even valid
and it says if the marriage contract has
been done and she's even reluctant it's
an invalid contract meaning it does not
exist you cannot silence doesn't mean
yes if she's scared or she's afraid to
talk about it like that it's an invalid
n like you cannot do that that's why bro
my I'm 25 if if my dad could force me to
get married I'm from an ethnic
background my dad would trust me he'd be
like come on like we need to go get you
married you're 25 but it's against our
religion like my dad cannot force me he
can show me people but he can never say
you have to get married what you're
showing us is just not it's not proven
anything to be honest with you it's just
writings from Islamic QA it's not even
given but I like that she went to Islam
Q&A because we're going to use Islam QA
to prove to prove the point here um
listen I use a lot of things not just
yeah it's all good it's all good but
look notice notice what in this Hadith
what the consent of a little virgin is
watch what the consent is this is sahim
Muslim 1419 a it says can I ask you a
question though like I know you're busy
but can I ask you like a real just
general question really the general
question to you is is this what makes
you think that Islam is a lie like
marriage it's one of them is it one okay
it's one yeah it's one of them it's big
it's a big issue for me not just
marriage is it's the it's the
permissibility of having relations with
little girls that's the problem we don't
I promise you none of us are sitting
here condemn like condoning Pia because
if anything you'll be surprised I've
done this for a very long time there are
Muslims that have come up and said yeah
so what that's what the Quran says yes
that's awful so what you know but the
thing is yeah like on a real note like
the thing is a lot of these ex-muslims
who were in Islam who speak Arabic who
have now left the fult of Islam do
actually come on and spread propaganda
and
indoctrination ex Muslims I'm not
talking about ex here on this act there
are Muslims who come up and they'll say
yes so what yes this is this is what
Allah has has made permissible whatever
Allah per permits you know allaham yeah
so what I don't have a problem with it
they come up and they defend this they
don't deny it for me it's just like the
logic of okay if Islam promotes child
marriage aside from countries like third
world countries and Villages and all of
that who are following culture as
opposed to religion like you don't see
where Dean is actually followed you
don't a NYE old with I can pull up so
many articles I can pull up so many
articles for you of little girls being
given to to old men in marriage in
Muslim countries I can pull all what
part but what part of the world I'm a so
I'm Afghan Persian midd
e and those types of things happen like
we also
have I'll show you like I can show you
that happens but that's also them
following conservatism and culture as
opposed to fine but look the I don't
even care what they I don't I don't care
if a Muslim never did this the fact that
it is taught in the religion itself is
what the problem is I I don't have a I
don't like if Muslims doing practicing
the religion or not practicing the
religion doesn't make the religion true
or false to me what makes the religion
true or false is what the religion
itself says so if the religion itself as
we're showing in its own sources is
giving allowance for this that's the
problem whether Muslims do it or not so
look here's the here's the consent of
the of the of the girl a woman without a
husband must not be married until she is
consulted and a virgin must not be
married until her permission is sought
they ask the prophet of Allah yeah
that's me finish it this is important
how how her virgin how her the Virgin
how is her consent how can her consent
be solicited you know how can you get
the consent of the Virgin watch what
Muhammad says he said they that she
keeps silence so her silence is her
consent the little virgin if she's quiet
that's that's a that's a yep you got you
got the green light bro I don't know
what to tell you because you don't think
that's crazy listen what the hell like
bro listen I'm telling you straight up
like that's not the Islam I follow I
don't know what your put not enough
knowledge to to debate you on this I'm
just going to be straight up I don't
have I'm not a scholar like I don't have
the knowledge to to tat to you you need
to speak to someone who's like a scholar
who can I have I've spoken I've spoken
to General Muslim from you know like I'm
trying to learn on my Dean and you know
these types of things I learn it every
day but you need to no you need to
speak King not even King peasant listen
to me
okay sorry I'm not calling no I'm I'm
being straight up like I'm not a scholar
I can't answer the questions I'm just
going to respectfully dip like it's not
fair wait don't leave yet don't don't
leave yet I'm not I'm not challenging
you Z look listen so notice how didn't I
didn't like try to make you you know
explain something or I didn't do nothing
I just was sharing with you my knowledge
and what I what I have found right so I
I don't expect you to have an answer for
everything or whatever I'm just giving
you what I know and a part of why I
reject Islam this is why because look I
know that when you said you said it so
important and what you said was so
important that this is not the Islam you
know this is not the dean that you
follow and I know that I know that you
have a particular view of Islam you
learned Islam as as you're growing up or
whatever in a a certain way and so
therefore what we're showing you is not
what you are familiar with I know that
what I'm saying is is that you have to
when you actually look into what Islam
actually teaches you look into the
actual sources look into what the Quran
actually says look into what the
scholars actually say you will see that
the Islam you know is not the true Islam
at all I promise you that's okay just
just think on that that's all I'll leave
you with the of the AY sister Z the
reason why this Ayah was revealed just
to give you a little bit of heads up
he's the companion of the Prophet you
know if we go
to just you know giving you a quick one
that he said because of some young ones
and he clarifies it he gives you you
know three category because it is
talking about three categories and he
mentions some of the young one as well
this is why the the Ayah was revealed
the of the ay okay now what logic showed
you this is in regarding the
four they give you the rulings of the
marriage do you know Zab sister with all
the respect that you know the ones who
have not reached the years of
administration obviously talking about
the young ones the little child ones
they had this three months now the has
been used for what we know for a fact
has been used for sexual intercourse why
because we can see according to
3349 you know it's talking about the
believing women if you do not touch them
and they you know they have no waiting
for the period for them to count now
what did Ahmed binel says and Abu once
she reaches n years old she is forced to
Bear intercourse this is what the
scholar says this is 90% of the scholars
that says and they're all agreeing to it
logic showed you many of the scholars
you
know the four which
is you know all of these you know and we
could go in deep but we don't want to
obiously you know overwhelm you you know
but we want you to please we love you we
don't hate you we want you just to kind
of do your own research think about it
think about it exactly that's all you
know respectfully guys like I'm just
going to say I don't have enough
knowledge to come and defend my religion
like this and I feel like it's not fair
for me to be advocating on Islam on a
panel with like 750 people where I do
not have that type of knowledge to call
it out so I feel like it's best that you
go to people who actually can you know
come and counteract what you're saying
so that it's fair like for me I'm just
you know from L like I don't have that
type knowledge I was born in a religion
that teaches and doesn't teach that and
obviously alhamdulillah I'm good with
what I have but you need somebody who
can give you that there obviously in
every religion you're not going to have
a pastor or a a nun or like a you're not
going to have the top top level people
who know their religion like that for me
personally I'm just a normal you know
person I'm learning every day myself and
I just don't think it's fair for me to
come up here so I respect you guys and I
hope that you guys can find somebody who
is able to maybe show you a different
understanding but I personally can't
offer you that but it was nice to speak
to you and can I just say I do not
promote and we as do not promote pilia
and I can stand you then you go against
Islam good no I
don't look z z before you go look
because I want you to follow me and I
want you to watch the conversations that
I have with Muslims I want you to watch
it and see how Muslims try to engage
with certain things that I bring up okay
so I think it'll interest you you know
so follow me and
zo how about we make uh I mean since
she's here if she has time she could
stay here and we bring someone to argue
in regarding the child marriage what do
you think I mean it's up to you about it
let her Let Her Go Let Her Go you you
can have me here if you want and I can
listen but it's up to you like I mean
somebody said somebody said use your
brains
like come on now I am I'm using my
intellect by telling people that I'm not
educated enough I think that's
respectful no I think that I think that
it's it's it's it's honorable it shows
your humility like okay I'm I'm not
knowledgeable to speak further on this
but don't let it rest there since you're
not knowledgeable on this issue get
knowledgeable on this issue and then
make a decision you know that's that's
that's what we're asking you to do what
is my what what a decision on what like
would you what on whether or not on
whether or not this is a religion right
that you can follow if it actually is
teaching this if it so what you need to
come to this conclusion does Islam
actually teach this as we're showing you
and if it does you have to be consistent
and condemn it right any religion that
teaches this you you would condemn you
know so you so you need to you know
inform yourself does it teach this or
not if it doesn't of course you know you
move on learn other things if it does
now you know that it does and therefore
you got you got to condemn this stuff
yeah no I agree can I just ask King
whatever no peasant sorry sorry I'm not
going to sorry I'm Habibi are you
ex-muslim because you are so obsessed
with
Muslims are you an ex-muslim are you an
ex-muslim S peasant are you I'm not an I
am not an
EXL well I am a CF you know I was born
in she already got it yeah you called it
already I see you I know you so well
your
people because I know your people sorry
sorry that was rude that was rude what
do you mean your people I mean I mean
like you know Iraqi some of the ones
that are like you know not on it they
are some lovely people but just have
some very strong views and I've come
across them before see I already know
your tactic because when you started
speaking Arabic I picked up the dialect
you see like I already knew what was
asked and then like
anyway he was just sharing truth he just
sharing true the thing is I've had this
conversation with Iraqis before and they
come with the same retoric with the same
stance with the same Arabic with the
same line so I was just like
yeah he was different though this was
this was not this was a different
conversation wasn't it well we'll see
but yeah keep keep coming through keep
watching you're welcome to stay and
watch as much as you want and you can
see how Muslims how Muslims deal okay
all righty I gave you a f awesome
awesome thank you if this wasn't a
horrible conversation so I appreciate
that we keep we keep we keep it cool
here look I have my views I have my
beliefs I don't hate anybody that
disagrees with me I don't pay them for
it is if we can have a honest
conversation we can do that oh my God
someone said I have a crush on you and
that you'll conver me to whatever Faith
you're on people are crazy I think they
talk about Sil who the hell is Sil
e gross sorry I don't date I don't marry
peasants you see anyways anyways those
are marriageable words I'm not going to
lie yeah my my bar ate that L okay all
righty all right take care Z take Bye by